買いすぎた
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
皆さんはコカコーラというものをご存知
でしょうか世の中にはいろんな飲み物が
あると思うんですけども
特に有名な性病飲料水それがコカコーラ
そりゃもう
美味しいですよてか美味しいから買ったん
です美味しいから買ったんですけども買い
すぎだーはいあのー
[音楽]
頼み過ぎましたなんか最近飲み物買いだめ
するようにしててめんどくさいじゃない
ですかその毎回買いに行くのだから水とか
もすごい階段目しててでコーラも絶対飲み
たくなるなと思って結構買いだめしたん
ですよ
それが100だったところは1000と
いうかちょっと0が1個多かったという
ことで
約1000本のコーラを私の家にと
ってどうすんのこれマジでマジでどうすん
のこれ
千本コーラが届きましたこれ1つ24本
入ってるから
984万1000本ですね1000本残る
のがおうちに届いちゃったもちろん伸び
ます飲みますけどもなんかコーラってさ
その美人がいいわけじゃないですかでも夜
によって太いやつ500mlの一番
おいしいやつ届いちゃったんですよ知っ
てる人もいるんですけどもコーラってこの
ね尾獣わかりますこの洗練された缶の
デザインめっちゃかっこいいんですよ
ショットチャンスこんなかっこいいものが
1000本届いたのであればなんかこれ
部屋中に飾ったらめっちゃかっこよくなる
んじゃないかなと思って今日はこんな素敵
なデザインのコカコーラのロング感が
1000本なんてなかなかないと思うので
ちょっと1回俺んちに並べてみるわ
1000本話はそこからだ
[音楽]
普通に埋まった机があるようになりました
ただ全然
千本どころじゃないなこれ
78箱ぐらいですね78箱ぐらいで
ようやくや
ば
めっちゃかっけえなんだこれ
全部使わずともかなり大きい俺が使ってる
机を埋まってしまいましたこれ何本かかっ
てるななんと198本で結構でかみの机が
埋まってしまいましたかっこよ全部これで
できてるこんなもうこのコカコーラファン
からすると普通に発狂もんでしょこれこれ
で大体200か
1000本だとこの部屋を全てコカコーラ
で埋め尽くすことは無理だと埋め尽くすの
は無理だけども点々と置くことはできると
思うのでちょっとまばらに1回俺んちを
コカコーラで埋め尽くしてコカコーラ
ワールドを作ってみたいと思いますんここ
からあるか
[音楽]
やば
チームをお待ちしております
[音楽]
はいというわけで無事にコカコーラ
ワールド完成しました
3時間かかりましたいやさすがせんも
1000本あればまあ
床が一面ぎっしりというわけにはいきませ
んけども
壁を見てください
全部コカコーラで埋め尽くすことができ
ました
結構マシの組場がないぐらいコカコーラで
埋め尽くすことができました
ただこんなことをするのにコカコーラを
並べるだけではないこれだけコーラに囲ま
れることなかなかないと思うんですけれど
もどうせだったらどうせだったらね
たくさん飲みたいじゃないですかという
わけで今手伝ってもらった後輩をちょっと
外にやってるんですけどももうちょっと
だけ改良したいと思いますよ
[音楽]
イケメンイケメンなんて言われてもね
いやいや説得力なし500倍イケメンその
5倍はイケメン山pが一番イケメンだから
なそうあれ
倒しちゃダメよコカコー
ラーのね宝
[音楽]
をはいというわけでご覧くださいこちら
コカコーラの山作ってしまいましたコカ
コーラワールド今完成してるわけですよ
この中にですね今お宝を隠しました私お宝
はい
アラビックヤマト隠しました
アラビックヤマトのりのアラビックヤマト
を隠しました宝です
うんこれは先に見つけた方が勝つ交互に
隠し合わせ
ナイスです難しいのが見つけるまでに
倒してしまったコカコーラを飲まなきゃ
いけないというルールです
ただほどあのぶつからずにこう
スパイのようにして
結構足のなんやかんあると思うのでなんと
かしてあの見つけば勝ちですなるほど
なるほど
簡単でしょ
お願いしますありがとうございますでは
ここねここはいってください
[音楽]
どこだどこだ
どこだ
え何やってんの
眉毛を切ってるのねマジ見つけるかね俺
じゃあ行きますね
レベル1でしょレベル1ですねいやそんな
だって2本倒したら1Lですから
ギャバどこだ
あったー
よしよしよしよしよしよし
よしよしよしよしよしよしゲットです最初
だけじゃこんなもんよねレベル1はねはい
じゃあ次俺のレベル1受けてもらおうぜ
[音楽]
いいかな
用意
[音楽]
さあまずは見つけるところからです
行けちゃうこれいい
じゃん飲みたくて1本倒しちゃうまである
ねこれおーなるほどね
[音楽]
もうクリアーいいじゃん一方
飲みたかったね
[音楽]
レディ
やったね
やったねなかなか高い位置にあるなぁ
いやーミスったー
直線じゃなかったこれ
倒さればいいんだもん倒さなきゃ大丈夫
らしいですよ
ああいいねいいねいいね
よし取りましたあとは帰るだけ変えるだけ
これマジでどう帰っちゃうの
[音楽]
今
1.5
[音楽]
リットルいただきます
いやいいな
伸びてこら
[音楽]
後でいいあとででいい
間違いなく今は無理この後健介レベル2の
挑戦なんですけども
彼には内緒で健介だけ突然レベル
9億6234万224
挑戦してもらいたいと思います
[音楽]
城で来とるよはいコーラシでですね
スタートです
[音楽]
普通に
どうやってたこれは
いなんか神殿の多くにあるっぽいですこれ
はなるほどねさあ
[音楽]
行くしかないよねこれ行くしかないですよ
ね
いきます
[音楽]